tes parents tu viens les boutiques sont
toutes fermées les gens viennent oui
mais visiblement pas suffisamment c'est
la saison des marchés publics car vous
le savez si vous êtes un amateur de
tomates fraîches si vous allez chercher
vos bleus et vos fraises et bien vous
savez c'est commencé depuis plusieurs
semaines donc tout le mois d'août mais
en fait c'est la onzième édition de la
semaine québécoise des marchés publics
est ce que vous venez de voir c'est un
extrait donc des réactions de gens qui
sont à longueuil dans le marché qui en
arrache présentement ce matin on reçoit
jean luc trudel qu'ils recteur général
de l'association des marchés publics du
québec monsieur trudel bonjour bonjour
vous avez vu en ces images à longueuil
des producteurs qui désertent qu'ils ne
sont plus là qui n'ont plus de kiosques
comment ça va les marchés publics qui
dans la province à travers la province
ça va très bien et on à l'association
des marchés publics du québec on eu 122
marchés publics membres chez nous donc
bon à mana et des marchés publics qui se
développe en a d'autres qui vit des
périodes de transition
donc c'est ce qu'on peut remarquer je
pense avec celui de longueuil et oui
c'est ça parce que ça ne fait pas quand
même quand on voit ça on aime ça aller
au marché que ce soit rentable aussi
pour les producteurs je te fais en fait
c'est la raison première quelques parts
d'un marché public en fait c'est de
faire faire des sous aux producteurs a
bien entendu mais à travers le québec en
or marcoussis qui ont une certaine
période de transition dans la saison les
producteurs
comment savoir plus abondante un peu
plus tard et un hacker qui accuse de
trois semaines de retard dans leur
production
donc on remarque aussi la clientèle va
peut-être venir plus de 100 marchés
publics un peu plus tard mais pour
l'instant sur l'ensemble du réseau
ça va très bien ça va bien et bon mais
ça ça ça nous rassure qu'est ce qui fait
le succès justement d'un et abusé d'un
marché public ou d'un événement autour
de marché le marché public repose à mon
sens sur trois piliers vraiment
importants premièrement les producteurs
nécessairement 6-1 paix dans leurs
marchés
c'est un bon facteur de succès sa part
généralement en fait c'est ce que les
gens vont chercher c'est ce que les
grandes surfaces ou les marchés privés
les revendeurs ne peuvent pas vraiment
offrir aux gens donc c'est ce qu'on va
chercher principalement et avoir le
contact avec les producteurs
ensuite même clientèle souvent que sont
bénévoles dans le marché à travers le
réseau je remarque beaucoup de gestion
des marchés publics de clients qui
deviennent bénévoles en fait qu'ils
s'impliquent dans leur marché pour
donner de l'animation de donner une idée
c'est à leur marché dans leur communauté
dans leur quartier et finalement
l'implication de la municipalité des
pouvoirs publics les marchés publics
font beaucoup avec peu donc une
municipalité que simplement son marché
des producteurs qui sont fidèles aux
marchés et qui contribuent à son
développement
une clientèle voire des bénévoles qui
s'impliquent aussi pour donner
l'identité du marché ces trois piliers
qui font en sorte que le marché public
comme une scission se développent et
connaît des succès sa demande
l'implication de tous finalement c'est
public donc effectivement pour les meufs
au soldat rose autour du marché public
c'est sûr que des fois y'a des périodes
de all souvent ce qu'on remarque des
gestionnaires qui comme son nom peut
plus précaires ils vont faire quelques
saisons mais il ya quand même du
changement important autour de cette
profession l'a donc nous comme
association travaille avec eux pour leur
fournir des outils de travail et faire
en sorte qu'on puisse développer les
marchés ce qui ne me sont provins
premier à l'association les marches vous
avez parlé également du rôle des villes
à travers les marchés on a vu que la
ville de longueuil est redevenu devenu
propriétaire en fait du marché a investi
des millions de dollars en avril dernier
pour essayer de garder le marché a envie
à quel point c'est important pour une
communauté d'avoir accès à ces produits
là à la fraîcheur aux producteurs en
fait justement la création du marché
public vaut aussi en réponse à ce que
bon les producteurs peuvent constater
conjointement que ce serait intéressant
d'investir une place publique pour
commercialiser leurs produits mais à l
inverse il ya beaucoup de citoyens de
groupes de citoyens en fait qu'ils nous
rejoignent l'association pour créer
leurs marchés qui ont fait leur devoir
en fait qu'on parle aux producteurs
environnants puis les autres ont déjà
savoir c'est intéressant pour eux de
devenir dans leur communauté
donc avec ce lien l'homme on peut mentir
un marché public va être prospère donc
les gens la population en réclame
davantage oui effectivement depuis les
cinq dernières années à l'association du
moins on a eu une augmentation de 40
membres environ donc ça va bien notre
but c'est pas de créer des marchés
publics à travers la province
another nous l'important oui dans
certaines régions c'est clair que ce
serait mieux d'en avoir plus ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est avec les marchés
fait mal les marchés qui sont de plus de
cet événement ciel c'est que ça comble
un espèce de
besoin du mercredi au dimanche donc
comme un chapelet de perles
les producteurs vont ce déplacement
différentes communautés de leur région
et vont rencontrer différentes
clientèles donc en choisissant ce mode
de commercialisation l'appui en allant
en différentes communautés mais
rencontrent une clientèle qui grossit et
comme vous l'avez dit on recherche le
contact avec le producteur de plus en
plus et c'est à travers les marchés
publics on peut l'obtenir le mieux à mon
sens la visite à la ferme ça en france
on voit ça beaucoup c'est marché nomade
donc qu'ils sont là pour quelques jours
mais qui se déplacent pour aller vers
une autre clientèle vous remarqué que ça
fonctionne bien ce mode là c'est pas
nécessairement des marchés qui se
déplacent mais c'est des marchés qui ont
des activités le mercredi d'autres le
jeudi et qui permettent aux producteurs
en fait de choisir ce mode de
commercialisation de leurs produits et
d'aller visiter différentes
organisations différentes municipalités
qui accueillent un marché public donc ça
leur permet de choisir le marché public
comme étant un mode de commercialisation
mais cela permet aussi rencontré une
différentes clientèles pitt s'est
déroulé un véhicule bien entendu il ya
montréal comment ça se passe pour les
différents marchés on a parlé beaucoup
de du marché jean-talon là
oui mais en fait je trouve que la
corporation de gestion des marchés
publics de montréal qui est qui manque
chez nous et je dois le dire font de
l'excellent travail au niveau du
développement
je crois qu'une restructuration qui lui
donnait dernières années on s'entend
c'est une grosse institution à montréal
les marchés jean talon ou les marchés
plus de montréal je peux parler au sens
plus large
donc je pense qu'il ya des bonnes années
à venir aussi derrière l'organisation il
ya madame la liberté qui fait de
l'excellent travail
nicolas fabien wallet aussi
l'organisation development qui qui
planchent sur des projets très
intéressants
en fait je crois que la restructuration
est quand même passé je veux dire il ya
quand même une équipe en place qui va
faire en sorte que ça va bien se
développer dans les prochaines années et
c'est une bonne nouvelle que les gens
s'informent sur leurs marchés publics la
santé de leurs marchés publics parce que
ultime ans ça veut dire qu'ils sont
préoccupées par leur alimentation de
manger local ça ça commençait de plus en
plus en vogue
donc tant mieux si on si on s'en
préoccuper en fait pillon se solidarise
derrière nos marchés pour les maintenir
plus développés donc 11e édition de la
semaine québécoise des marchés publics
différentes activités internet parole
gilles aubé fait la tournée à travers le
québec aujourd'hui tav à rien de mettre
aux rivières on la voit un peu partout
et fait le tour de la gaspésie aller à
la rencontre des marchés publics tous la
clientèle donc une invitation de
fréquenter votre marché bien entendu
mais aussi les visites et si vous êtes
en vacances ou dans votre région c'est
lancé j'en ai cru dès merci beaucoup
d'avoir été leur plus vous revoir